oops
all right
we ready fam
jacob jiminez what is up alex castro and
amir
ali production max conrad what's up my
dude loki's in the chat
hey what's up hunter forsaken what up
what is going up sounds like i have
audio
i think we're good all right
what is up hey if better notice every
single thing on the first viewing
according to the real rejects
where they're gonna come find me and uh
they're gonna get me
greg always threatens me all the time
and john sends me mean things
in the mail they do that
not really greg and john are the best i
talked to greg
a lot and he watches me
all right i think we got it i think
we're good thank you yes
i like to check too and it's actually
cold in here
because when we when we work all night
uh for these loki for the loki
episodes and same thing for like you
know any of the
the shows that come out where i have to
be up all night our computer isn't super
hot
and uh it gets really really hot so i
cranked down the ac
so uh so i could actually be cold
what's loki's favorite country
lol is this
is this is this joke i don't i don't
know
what is up everybody so do we do we
think do you think kang is coming
is that are we thinking something like
that you know i
uh i don't want to start the whole
uh mephisto thing again
you know what i mean so i i don't want
to do that again
but i i genuinely do think that like out
of everything that makes sense
like that makes sense the most you know
what i mean
like king makes sense the most
so if there's a villain
that is the loki villain
i'm thinking it's king because why why
like why
you're gonna introduce him anyways
so why not just you know set him up set
him up set him up
yes everybody real rejects were in here
uh greg still might be lurking around
but yeah me and greg are really good
friends
and they're really good guys wait did my
stream freeze oh
nope we seem good we seem pretty
collab with new rock stars um i was on
one of their rogue theories once i don't
think they do too many collabs though
um and it seems like now they have like
a pretty set
rogue theory hey infinity shades thanks
for the super chat do you think it would
be weird if looking lady look you got
together
i mean would that be like incest piano i
know that's such a weird question it's
not
like a weird question it's like a very
common question that i think a lot of
people are asking
and uh i don't know am i weird for not
thinking it's weird
i mean
is it weird for like wanting it
it's weird right yeah it's like it's
like a weird thing to ask
um it's definitely a weird
thing to to think about
uh but it's like you kind of want it
right it's like it's kind of weird that
you you kind of you kind of want it
right i mean it's uh yeah i
just recorded a um
uh loki origin video for my other small
channel superhero central that i post
to like once a month i've like really
tried to post to it more but
life gets busy you know life gets busy
i'm grateful for all the support i have
on uh
on this show on the cosmic wonder and
i'm grateful for our view let's just
make sure everything's working all right
yes sir yes sir yes ma'am yes ma'am
everything seems to be
seems to be going good let's do it let's
do it
all right what is it coming out uh
i'm gonna say 25 minutes so i have cats
running around the back
making noise there's one right there cat
that's that's actually rocket who i
named after rocker raccoon
hi rocket anyone come here
she knows i'm live
[Laughter]
uh i i i see a few people
asking like what to expect from episode
four
uh i'm gonna say it's gonna be
revealing only because tom
hiddleston said
he said by the end of the fourth
beginning of the fifth that's when it
starts to kind of get
crazy what did he say he said poor loki
which i found funny
because because yeah that's rabbit
that's funny
yeah so
for those people who are wondering kang
is i saw a few comments not sure if it's
from a bunch of people the same person
um kang is basically the master of time
travel
um he started off in the future
uh franklin no no not franklin richards
uh
franklin richards is an extremely
powerful
mutant that i actually personally can't
really wait till he gets in the mcu
but um he's a descendant of
well they kind of like change it in the
comics a little bit he's a descendant of
reed richard slash uh doctor doom they
look
like in the comics like more recently
they thought that he could be a decent
doctor doom
um but basically he exists like way into
the future
um where time travel is has been
discovered
nathaniel richards is his name thank you
um
he exists way in the future where time
travel is illegal and he stumbles upon
you know time travel equipment any time
travels he basically
uh kind of becomes the ruler of egypt at
the time
um and from there pretty much
the fantastic four kind of thwarted
plans
and then from there on out he pretty
much hates the fantastic four in the
avengers because they
they thought his plans as well and there
are good versions of him
um like iron lad and i won't
my audio is super low
hello hello is it let me check this
heard a few people mention it
sorry if it's low i uh i think it's i
think it's doing all right right now
um when will episode 4 come out guys uh
probably like 20 minutes i'll do a
little i'll do a little check here
just to make sure it's not already out
because you never know with disney plus
sometimes they release it i remember
like for
for one division they released it like
super early one time like one day it was
like really really early and i was like
oh dang
no it's not out yet momentous um
so some do i think loki will join
the 2023 timeline
would i assume what i assume you mean
is like the main timeline where we're at
right now
and i hope so and i really hope sylvie
goes with him because i i really like
sylvie and i think that
the dynamic between them is is really
good i
i i really really like like watching
them interact i think it's really cool
so i hope so um i think
i i definitely think that by the end of
this
this show you know it's going to be
multiverse of madness
you know um
it's going to be super multiverse
madness like we've already kind of seen
it
hold on real fast sean thank you so much
for that super chat again i know you
drop a few
uh you've dropped a few in the past as
well thank you so much the ancient one
of the avengers
disagree with tva on the multiverse what
are the secret timelines just one big
lie
and desperate power trip you know that
very well could be
um i will say
that it seems like the tva does have
everything in check
um but does that mean so
what like to add to your your question
and comment
i actually think that you know
i'm not going to say it's kang i do
think it's king right but not anywhere
confirmed yet but let's say the time
keepers
what if they have like they clearly have
an agenda of their own obviously right
so what if they like make timelines on
purpose
right and they do things in that
timeline and all this other stuff
right i mean what happens there so
do i play brawl stars i don't know what
that is i'm sorry
sorry so no i i don't play it's old loki
all along
yeah maybe we'll see him in this episode
maybe richard he grant will come in this
episode oh did i
did i miss the super chat i'm sorry
peter colerton thanks so much do you
think daredevil would definitely mean
spider-man i need him too
so this is like it's this is a word play
question
do i think daredevil is going to be in
it no do i think matt murdock is going
to be in it
yes you get what i'm saying like
every report that i said we're going to
see matt murdock
most of them have said we're not seeing
daredevil
so as weird as that sounds uh
weird right but you know i'd really
really really really like to see him
um
and i hope it's i hope it's the same guy
you know um
let's check i know a few people are
asking when's the episode
it's not going to be out yet i bet yeah
so only three here i'll just kind of
show you guys what i'm
what i'm looking at right now uh this
one yeah so not out yet still just
showing three
so there's something the wolf around the
world thanks for super chat
could be possible to see other variants
of the avengers like tony stark and the
future of the mcu absolutely and i
think that's what it's all building up
to i've uh
i've said it i've said it in enough
videos
um that some of you might be tired of
hearing it but i i definitely think this
is all leading up to secret wars like
uh 100 i think it's all leading up to
secret wars and
uh there's two different stories of
secret wars but basically um
on battle world you get a bunch of
different
we'll call them variants uh of you know
people so like multiple iron mans
multiple
x-men multiple captain americas you know
much of the same people
and um that's one of the really like
it's a great story and i think if marvel
does it right i think they are doing it
right
it'll beat infinity war and end game if
and as weird as that sounds but it
totally will
because so really with what loki is
doing
and time travel and alternate timelines
in the multiverse
anything is possible like literally
anything is possible
so like we could excuse me
oh hold on
sorry guys oh so literally anything's
possible
um we could see robert downey junior
return we could see scarlett johansson
return now
to be playing alternate version they're
variants of themselves right
uh am i a fan of blackpink yes i
randomly saw blackpink actually i just
booked i just bought my tickets to see
their
movie coming out in a theater nearby me
like an hour ago
uh do i think kang will show up in the
series
yeah i i just i i just think it makes so
much sense
and i don't want to say it's a missed
opportunity if he if he doesn't appear
um i just think it makes so much sense
uh
yeah 12 a.m california time which is uh
almost almost
what is the end credit scene for black
widow i can't
tell you that um have you ever done a
collab with anyone yes i've done a club
with many people
um the real rejects new rock stars the
canadian lad
cosmic culture which is like my other
channel slash the channel that my buddy
chris runs
um someone said google
cast is wrong yeah a lot of the times it
is uh karen shaw thank you
uh thank you i like my jacket i'm glad
you like it too
um oh did i miss the super chat i don't
ever want to miss super chats
infinity shades whoa thanks for that
super chat really hoping some marvel do
marvel does some darker movies with
darker characters like daredevil
punisher blade ghost writer personally
think keanu reeves would be a great
ghost star oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's like what i'm gunning for is
kannaris was ghostwriter and uh the
midnight suns like you basically just
described the midnight suns uh and
that's what i would love to see and i
hope blade
kind of goes you know kind of goes
darker um
you know the other one the old not a lot
of people realize this because they
haven't seen the old blade movies ryan
reynolds is
in uh old played movies and
i think that would be a great deadpool
joke if he ever ran into blade in the mc
would be hilarious
uh they are different variants of loki
so is there a variant of loki as a
tick-tock star
minecraft character just curious thank
you in amir ali productions
yeah i mean in theory right and we i
don't know what they're going to show us
but in theory there's probably a
different variant of loki for
you know essentially everything because
if you look at like the variant
that that he is it was like 1 000
something so
i i just got your super chat in the
mirror sorry i and if there was another
one
that i i deeply apologize i just
scrolled and addressed that one
um i don't think i missed it i think i
met a blade as long as loki show airs
i'm gonna wear this jacket
and i have a sticky note tesseract like
these are literally sticky notes
like i see the bottom it's
i'm not gonna open it because because i
kind of have a tesseract now right
without it i i don't uh
love back to india where's my miss
minutes she's
there miss minutes clock i need a hanger
hang her uh
hello hello hello ninja nation army
uh dante gaines will ms fisto have
appeared in the mcu
i mean
this is what got me in trouble before
not in trouble but um
i say yes i i say yes
and if you if you think about this i
don't think the mcu
is ever going away
like maybe a hundred years from now but
i don't i don't think
i don't think it's going away so
ultimately you're gonna
you know use the characters and i think
mephisto just kind of makes sense
and i would laugh at this whole entire
time you know marvel's kind of like
making fun of us for all these theories
but then in the end it's like it was
mephisto all along you know i think that
would be pretty funny i missed the super
chat
t nasty nelson hey what's up man i never
check my insta messages it depends if
it's on my
cosmic wonder official account i really
don't check my messages a lot and the
reason is and i'll just explain this to
everybody right now
people call me on instagram all the time
and it's very annoying um not that i
don't want to talk to everybody
obviously but like
just in my normal life as i'm like at
the gym or like eating and all the stuff
like
i used to like reply to a lot and then a
lot of people would like
because once you reply to something that
gives them the option to like
facetime call you through instagram call
you through instagram and my phone would
just like blow up so
i don't really for that reason sadly i
don't reply to much
um but i do on my personal instagram uh
do i like dc characters yes
i love dc um i hope
it's i hope they're getting their
universe together and it sounds like
they are with the flash movie
so uh jaden 1911
for everything thank you what i think
about the future spider-man deadpool
um be a shame if they never interacted
be a big shame oh i missed the super
chat
i saw i think it was from max
yeah max what's up man um do i think
they'll turn sylvian to a kid uh
no but but i'm really really hoping that
we see her backstory um
do you like the one thing uh for those
asking no i haven't seen episode four i
only saw the first two episodes and uh
oh and i'll address this because i saw
somebody um
asked me before so the way disney sends
out
their screeners is what they're called
um
is they it's a it's a website link that
they send
and like when i first got on board with
them you
you have to like make an account you
have to do all this blah blah blah and
then disney has to verify it
and then it's like coded and all the
stuff and each time you log in you have
to like
agree to this agree to this agree to
this like all these legal things
uh basically say like we're gonna sue
you if you you know show anybody
anything and it's like yep i agree
you're gonna sue me and take everything
i got
um so it's kind of funny and then you
get to just basically watch it and
it depends on what it is like black wood
i think i had 48 hours
um there was like a 48 hour window like
two weeks ago and then like
last night and the day before there was
like another 48 hour window to watch it
um this the series like loki and them
they're they're on there for
a few days i think so uh braden larussa
thank you for the super shot what time
is it there probably about 10 minutes
uh jeffrey chang completely not marvel
related but are there
any other k-pop groups you like besides
black pink yes
i actually primarily just listen to
k-pop not just listen to k-pop
um but twice they just released their
new song perfect world today
and it is fire like it is really really
good so i love twice
um got7 which i heard they're
not breaking up but changing labels
which i really i'm glad because i really
like got7 um
straight kids hyuna hyuna is actually
what got me into k-pop she got me into
k-pop like a really really long time ago
um itsy i really like itsy they've been
they've been pretty good where did i buy
the jacket i didn't uh buy the jacket
uh disney sent it to me loki reed
loki is opf yeah and i was doing my
excuse me i was doing my um
origin story from my other channel
superhero central and
i i'm just like re like reading about
some more powers that i forgot that he
had
and i'm just like oh my gosh look he's
like i'm so glad that like they didn't
just kill him off because he's such a
great villain he's so powerful and tom
hiddleston just does
a super super great job flying nan
creator's favorite marvel film or series
that's like such a hard so if we're
gonna take away
i always say this if we're gonna take
away avengers infinity war and avengers
end game
uh i'm probably a thor ragnarok guy
i just really love that film and thor is
my favorite marvel character so
i just i really love that film um
so i mean but if we don't take away
those i i rank infinity war actually
higher than in game but the two of them
are my favorite
uh teenagers on 50 50. if you look you
survive lucky weird lovers
um yeah right i mean same here i i guess
um
same here i guess yeah so i i wouldn't
i'm not gonna be
mad if they like hook up right i because
it would be a loki thing right it would
it's like such a loki thing to like hook
up with himself like can you like
right like it's such a loki thing
i just i wouldn't be surprised is it
weird i don't know
everyone keeps asking me i don't know
like you guys i
is it weird is it incest
it's such a weird thing to talk about
but hey uh
let me see if it's out
not yet not for me let's do one more
refresh
nope not for me not yet uh do i think
loki is going to meet kang on the show i
i hope i hope so i think i hope we
i hope we all do uh a trey but
charia so sorry if i butchered your name
i probably did
um the fourth and fifth episodes are
going to have major indians yeah that's
what uh tom hiddleston himself said
well hey armin collab with canadian lab
we actually have collab before we've
collabed actually
uh a few times um
i i like that guy a lot i'm actually
trying to to help him get these
screeners too
um i've i've made some emails about it
try not to you know jeopardize my own
relationship with them but he's a
he's an awesome guy his videos are
freaking crazy uh
in a really good way right canadian is
awesome there's a lot of guys love out
there
heavy spoilers they're real rejects
canadian lad
paul kickball heavy spoilers is a funny
dude he he really is a genuinely funny
dude
do you think loki will be in the mcu
after this uh
akshat kim pavi yeah
yeah are the sphinx tv spots real
um i i didn't actually see the tv spot i
just saw
pictures of them so if you actually saw
them yeah they're real because i
remember like
for spider-man no way home like they
would put like
tv spots on like youtube for as like
youtube ads and like they wouldn't
actually be on tv
and people like oh they're fake and i'm
like no they're not they're just not
widely shown uh
t nasty nelson thanks again for that
super chat i feel like they're going
with the only person loki could love in
the senses himself herself just my
theory of show was going
well we made a joke last watch party
that's like oh
message of the of the show is love
yourself like
in like a really really weird way uh
i can't tell you who taskmaster is
uh in black widow but i enjoyed
who it was um
and i honestly can't tell you the post
credit scene for those asking
for darkseid yeah ryan what'd you guys
think of snyder's
cut the snyder cut of justice league i
think it was freaking amazing
do you think they'll tease netflix
characters like iron fist and chinchi uh
i hope so but i don't think it'll be the
actual character from
netflix sadly oh it's out
the nexus event that's the title
all right we are going for all of you
we're going to watch it with me
we're doing a three two one
we have clicked on it we're going
yup
see
it is out
previously on loki
nexus this is going to be intense guys
this is going to be intense
oh sorry
whoops that's not it
to the end of the world
all right that's where they left off
last let's see what starts
nexus event
yeah so if you're new obviously
i can't show the whole thing and i can't
play the sound or i'm gonna get
in trouble obviously because that's
illegal
you can't just stream the show but we
watch it together we react together
i'm uh the logo just turned green
and we are diving into it now what's the
first thing we see
wind blowing
oh it's asgard
it looks slightly
oh no
there's our variant
they arrest the little girl this is is
this little sylvie
oh no
this is little so they arrested little
sylvie
oh no i want to know why
why you know there's a girl variant not
that i'm complaining because i
absolutely love it but i want to know
like the logistics behind it
like why what makes each loki variant
different
oh dang oh dang
oh help him what are you gonna do oh
look it's this guy
oh no
oh no
i wonder what they're going to say her
crime was
oh it wasn't there's a different person
oh is that rinse layer
it is
oh no way
look at oh dang so ren slayer wasn't
always a judge
no way
oh my gosh is she going to see the
timekeepers right now
oh my gosh she is
holy crap
oh my gosh oh my gosh
no way
holy crap
wow
no way
oh
dang
they can't blame you they can and do
do you have an idea how impossible it is
i need he needs access 100 c 20.
she kept saying it's real it's real
oh snap she's dead
she's not dead they're lying
she scrambled her mind
she's not dead
so they say c20
died but i'm not i'm not buying it
i'm not buying it
oh mr anderson what did you think of
that shot of the timekeepers man
what you guys think oh man that was so
cool
oh and here we're back to uh
here we're back to the destruction of
lamentus one
oh here's that infamous scene that
we all saw on the trailers y'all just
sitting in the open waiting to die
dang
i'm sorry
so how'd you get blonde she said i
remember asgard
please tell us more please tell us more
please tell us more
the universe wants to break free
so the okay
okay
and then she escaped she's just a child
excuse me
so everywhere she went across the nexus
event
because she's not supposed to exist
dang
dang
yeah you ain't dying here oh that's
super cool looking though
okay
oh she pissed
she's pissed
oh she asked about c20 but she's dead
oh snap that's cool
oh wow look at that oh it's yeah it's
like over
that's pretty freaking cool looking but
i'm confused i thought the planet was
running into the moon which i didn't
think made sense but
here we are where we are
what makes a loki a loki is the fact
that we're destined to lose that's sad
look he says we may lose but we don't
die we survive
i caught her amazing
they're touching each other oh they
found him
oof
are they they're just gonna accept this
oh they're holding hands waiting to die
oh it's kind of nice touching
so it's a weird branch they're creating
oh look at that
oh it's like growing super fast into a
nexus event oh it's going to create a
nexus event
wow look at that no way
go go go go go don't question it just go
they took him wow
oh
dang
get them lucky gosh i want the two of
them to live
i should have an equal amount of
security this is insulting
the folksy dopey insult
dang what's ready no no no no no no
you'll see
one last desperate trick
oh he said it he said the tv is lying to
you
dang it where's he going oh snap
this is a prison
no way no way
sith
she need him in the balls
yeah we do talk about spoilers in here
guys i i show most of the episodes so
oh he's reliving it
so is that like what hell is
like the repetition of it over and over
and over again
time loops so
and there she is
he's just gonna she's just gonna keep
getting kicked in the balls over and
over again
she's gonna kick him in the balls again
i mean i guess that would be hell just
getting kicked in the balls over and
over and over again
infinitely
so he's softening in the time cell it's
a time cell that's pretty cool
loki i've come to bargain
so again toys guys we talk about
spoilers a lot and we show stuff so uh
mobius is trying to
talk to the other loki rinslayer says no
work your loki and figure out what
caused that spike
timekeepers are always watching
we brought in cree titans vampires
but the two vampires oh my gosh
i just realized that they said freaking
vampires titans obviously is
i think they're talking about thanos
interesting she asked him if he said
anything and he said yeah
he said the tv is lying to me and she
seemed to believe that that would be
real
and uh loki's just getting kicked in the
nuts over and over again
please no more i beg you
i cut up here because i thought it would
be funny
dang
it's 47 minutes oh i said i crave
attention
because i'm because i'm a narcissist
i'm scared of being alone
whoa did she just offer him the hand no
she's gonna kick him in the nuts again
is she gonna keep my nuts again you are
alone
and you always will be kicked to the
nuts
oh she didn't kick him in the nuts
hey there he is
it's about to go down
he's ready to talk i mean what is he
gonna
okay here we go
big talk between mobius and loki
he said
if you're not working for the variant
are your partners
no she's difficult
yeah jay i think mobius will team loki
no we're not partners
you know means to an end
oh he says we've reached the dead end
now
give my regards to lady seth
oh that struck a chord with them
interesting
hmm
yep you tell them but
the variant she's gone
he's lying
uh yes episodes out we are watching it
right now there's a lot of deception
going on right here
hello imperial gamer
mobius knows and look he's lying
look at your eyes you like her does she
like you
you're swooning over each other
two variants forming a room
twisted romantic relationship
oh
fell for hurt yourself
is she alive
dang i like this
dang your female
self that you have a crush on
he just told him
you just told mobius spoilers by the way
guys
he just told mobius that he's a variant
you had a family before
a life et cetera et cetera i wonder if
mobius believes him i mean that's your
love for jet skis
right
wherever you go just the destruction
i don't need you anymore
dang
because i lied about your girlfriend no
that i can respect dang
hey what's up her hit she well she well
oh she what is she like believe in it
what is it what is happening here
oh she's like remembering or something
oh sh she's gonna help
did you get them all verified through
deletion
okay
there's something happening here oh snap
oh she's gonna go
try to kill loki
what's gonna happen here
oh hi sylvia
oh she put it down
oh she's helping her escape no way oh
no way she said come with me what
unexpected
okay now mobius is with rinslayer
how much more the episodes left okay
good about good morning
i don't need this to end yet oh my gosh
she's a case closed and they choose
dude what if what if mobius is king can
you imagine
he could go anywhere anytime
oh
huh
i said i like being here with you
so they wanna the timekeepers are
finally gonna meet mobius dang
although they're gonna delete him
uh 47 minutes is how long it is
the timekeepers are happy mission
accomplished
there are spoilers in here so if you
don't want them
i don't like telling people to leave but
mobius totally believes loki
something seems a little off
oh you want the truth tell me the truth
so she said i wouldn't let mobius interv
in her
interrogate not interview silva because
she was afraid
i've been too much time with loki's
so she's totally digging mobius
but i think she's using him
unfortunately which i
really don't like he said it was a good
speech
i knew
what is that sylvie's sword
opius is doing something mobius switched
devices with her oh
no way
um
so he took her i can't remember what
they call those devices
temp temp pad
let's finish this for all time always
i'll see you up there
so dang
okay so
[Music]
b15 just took her somewhere
to rockstar okay
just telling her the truth
she just told her your variants the
timekeepers basically kidnapped you
me okay
oh no way
dang
oh she remembers oh it's about to go
down
of course the episode's probably not the
end
oh she showed her oh
she says she looked happy
oh she said what now oh b15 is about to
help the loki's
yeah i agree with the chat uh miss
minutes is definitely
something oh moebius took her temp pad
what are we about to find
out
come on come on come on give it to me
show me show me show me
searching searching
oh she is dead oh that's that's sad
hunter c20 is dead
oh oh
when she was saying it's real it's real
she was talking about her old life
oh he knows now
oh yeah she knows he knows oh
moby's figuring it out oh
hey thanks for stopping by sorry for the
spoilers if you don't want to see him
loki's just get kicked in the nuts over
and over and over again
he's here
shut up
they're working together now
dang
i have to trust the word of two loki's
oh caught him a friend
you're right about the tva
oh he said if you want to save her you
have to trust me
oh you could be whoever you want to be
even someone good
no way all right so what's happening
here
oh that's not good
so what happens now
oh
dang
dang maybe i had a jet ski
that's what i'd like to do
prune it no what
uh
i'm so pissed off
oh you know what it was an illusion i
bet you it was illusion i bet you was
illusion
oh do i scare my cat oh please be an
illusion please be an illusion
please be an illusion oh please be an
illusion
oh no no no no please be an illusion oh
no no no
what is happening what is happening what
is happening what is happening
put out an alert for hunter b15 oh my
gosh
so is rinslayer just the main villain of
it all
oh
oh i like that music
dang all right as i said are they going
in front of the time keepers
dang one of the time keepers
better be like my name is nathaniel
oh snap it's happening oh my gosh it's
happening
oh my did they really do that
my gosh
oops do you remember me
oof what do you want to say to me
what was her nexus event yeah i want to
know why what did she
dude
oh that's rude she said what's her next
event ren slayer said i don't remember
yes she does you're a liar
oh snap here we go they're there they're
there with the time keepers
[Music]
gracious time keepers
holy crap spoilers obviously a huge was
oh wow
you and your bravado are no threat to us
that's okay that's gotta be king
you're nothing but a cosmic
disappointment
oh snap what's happening oh
oh now they're in front of the
timekeepers
oh no way it's gonna end here
oh she threw her sword
dude what is happening no way
look at this crap man
oh she's straight up stabbed him
why aren't they pruning they're trying
to prune them
oh snap no way let's do it
holy crap what is this
oh
oh no
oh no no no no no come on lucky lucky
help sylvie
okay no one's pruned though
oh what is it what
they are robots
where's the real oh gosh guys horror
like big spoilers coming
if you don't want spoilers you need to
get out now because i am going to be
talking about all of it
they're clearly robots which is
hilarious
so who controls them
dude i knew it i knew they weren't real
i knew they weren't real
so where's rinslayer
i did she's gonna say i did she's gonna
say i did
the hell's rinse layer she's gone
dude it's gotta be king right i mean
holy crap
i have to tell you something
back on momentous
come on oh he's touching her it's gonna
create a nexus event
he's gonna kiss her no
you're gonna tell me everything
what in the actual
hell
i don't know what to say
what the hell oh my god like i
oh my gosh i have
what the hell i uh i don't have words
[Music]
uh
there's a post credit scene
okay i post credit scene post credit
scene post credit seeing post credits
and post credits and post credit scene
no way no way no way are you alive
this is hell
not yet all right spoilers coming guys
spoilers coming
you will be dead unless you come with us
oh oh
oh no way
there's that was richard he grant
oh no way is there another post credit
scene
oh okay i'm
happy oh
oh okay i'm i'm okay
i'm okay i was very upset before
oh this this episode
took us for a freaking ride wow what a
great episode
uh i feel like
we haven't had that in a while um
i feel like we haven't had that in a
while i i
alright that was
let's get chris in here hello
christopher
let me fix this holy crap
marvel hasn't done this in a while
this is
oh i don't think anybody can hear you
yet or see you give me a second chat
how do i like oh yeah no i need to make
it to where it's like just you how do i
do that
you just click on me click go away
advertisement okay
um uh i i
oh no words
i literally was
yeah that that's hard that's hard to
even wrap your head around everything
just happened
first off i'm so bummed out about mobius
i i don't think he died i don't i don't
think he died what oh i was gonna say
loki's not dead look he's not dead
it looks like they're in that broken new
york city post-avengers war
place that we see in the trailers yeah
yeah maybe they so maybe that's where
they get sent to this junk world and
mobius is there somewhere
yeah maybe it's like a just some type of
car yeah like a crap for freaking
everybody
and i didn't know about a gator loki so
that's kind of cool
gator loki kid loki old loki
old loki there was richard grant which
we
talked about timekeepers aren't real i
freaking called that from the beginning
yeah but who's the is it guppy kings i
think it's king i feel like it's king
or hammer that um
this other loki has i don't know
and you recognize you're gonna have to
let me go take a
fire stick amazing 10 out of an episode
we're staying up three and four
absolutely like oh my gosh like i'm i'm
sick like that's how good it was that
was that i don't think we've gotten
anything that spectacular for marvel yet
i think that much of a reveal yeah that
wasn't
so much oh it was it was just such a
i was it was just such like a up and
down like emotional
like oh like my stomach i was like dude
i
literally i'm gonna have to like put a
reaction to me
reacting i think i needed to do it
because my reaction
i yelled i i heard you i screwed i
i was like no um
oh my gosh because like
let me let me go back to this post
credit scene real quick and let me take
a look at these guys
yeah that's uh there's some type of
hammer i don't recognize it from the
comics
unless it's like some weird type of
mueller that
i don't recognize it yeah they're
definitely in new york
my brain's broken dude yeah let me show
you chat
this is new this is definitely the
avengers tower right here
kid loki richard granold loki
african-american loki with a interesting
hammer
and gator loki
gosh that was so good that was so good
uh jackson loki
like vintage town in the background post
credit yep or it looks like it yeah yeah
jackson thanks for supporting
that looks like that's totally it i mean
guys that i mean
i mean it's gonna take a second just
even
insanity okay so like this set the bar
for me
for the best episode of any mcu disney
plus show we got so far but then
five days ago tom hiddleston says buckle
your seatbelt episode five and six or
so what he said was the ending of four
and then the beginning of five is where
it
gets
crazy i mean who knows what happens next
well but it set the bar
like right i loved one of vision i love
the falcon on the winter soldier but
none of the episodes compared to like
this
like this is huge absolutely down and
this is down yeah hey halo stripe happy
birthday
yeah this is like insane so moebius
better
freaking be there or i'm gonna be pissed
maybe rent slayer is the female version
of king
do you think i mean it would make sense
right
but i don't know she was a hunter before
she was a hundred before we kind of saw
her past right she was a hunter
but what if kang picked up the female
variant of him and groomed her through
i mean yeah that could totally be what
it is i i still think
it's gotta be kang that controls i mean
who else could it
possibly be and i knew i knew the
timekeepers weren't freaking real i
freaking knew they weren't real i knew
it
like there's just like zero possibility
that they were real i i was just like
but okay but here's the deal whoever is
controlling them has to be
uh like ins like a god essentially
that's what i'm saying like there's
literally like
on your hands the amount of people who
it could be yeah
like we could list off everybody capable
of doing this right now and the only
person that would make sense of the one
character who's been confirmed
to be in the emcee so that's the thing
right is kang is confirmed to be coming
to the mcu right
uh there is no galactus there is no like
none of this but that's the but that's
the other question right
is it kang or are they gonna introduce
like a cosmic entity out of nowhere
right like
the one above all or like the living
tribunal or something like that
i don't think those make sense i think
king makes the most sense i think that's
like
that's what it is because it's time it's
a time
it's right it's all about time realm
there's so many elements
this is happening kang is confirmed to
come to the mcu and ant-man
quantomanium like
uh trevz yeah the agatha reveal was
pretty great but i knew it was
yeah everybody ever right and i knew i
knew that
i had a hunch that the timekeepers
weren't real
but i didn't know and i think just the
fact of like mobius dying
uh loki getting zapped at the end but
then realizing and then the post-credits
scene
he didn't get zapped and then you know
the other lucky show oh my gosh
i'm in i don't think mobius is dead i
don't think so either i mean how would
loki
not be right so there's just some type
of multiverse
some type of realm parallel universe
where they're pruning sticks send
everything
right it's what it seems like right or
[Music]
did maybe mobius planned it maybe
hunter b15 helped uh i'm not sure
taylor hendricks thank you for that
super chat i love your channel all the
work you put into it oh thank you so
much
uh i make the show's better thank you do
you think loki and sylvia will see each
other again i i hope so
and i'm pretty sure he was about to tell
sylvie slash himself that he loved her
slash himself
and up for it i you know what if it
took a version of himself for him to
fall in love
who the hell are we to say the other one
we said it last
we said it since episode two i think
maybe
last episode um what moral of loki love
yourself
story of loki love yourself i
um i
i yelled so i just yelled when i woke up
i see that coming
like
yeah oh infinity shades
another super chat what up theory that's
my mind dude
that's a recovery maybe the villain is
dr diekovich and he's going after loki
for not paying rent
that joke i have a theory
from infinity shades the other loki at
the credit scene has a version of thor's
hammer for shadowing that our loki is
going to be
worthy eventually i hope so i would see
yeah yeah so i mean at the post credit
scene
we had our different variants of loki i
said they could hear warren over my
stream
what do you mean oh what i yelled you
were like yeah you're a hell
out i was so pissed no i was i was in
absolute disarray man
it was and then right after so mobius
got pruned i guess that's what they call
it yeah
and i
was sitting there while they're fighting
them like honestly either one of these
characters could get pruned they just
got rid of mobius like i didn't think
maybe they brought back the life like we
saw in the post credit but i'm like
and then they went to look at each other
and i'm like loki's gonna get stabbed
i reacted more to mobius than loki i was
so surprised
because it was a surprise right it was a
huge surprise
uh ty seal thanks for super chat so now
we have at least six young avengers
wiccan speed patriot hawkeye stature now
kid loki
will be getting this soon yeah i hope so
i don't think like
i don't think like i think like three
years or something like that
i mean it all depends if they're gonna
just go ahead and burst open the
multiverse right into
you know the spider-man with the
spider-verse coming where it starts yeah
just dr strange and if doctor strange
can't get it back together
i mean the mcu might be heading in a
very different direction
very very and i think you have to
because like how do you
out do the infinity saga i think we're
witnessing it in all honesty
i really do um hold on real fast
corn thanks for the super chat on imdb
owen wilson is in five episodes so he
will be in the last two episodes i
really hope so sometimes an indb
uh it's unclear on who's like doing all
that so i
uh i really hope i really hope that's
true
uh nitro flare youtube lifestyle super
chat what if loki's
loki's plural are immune to pruning
because of this they are instead sent to
a local world that is ruled by king loki
i think it'd be pretty sick
um i would be disappointed because that
would mean mobius is dead
and i don't want him to freaking be dead
uh pirate man i think super chat they
could have let owen wilson say wow right
before he got trimmed i
know right wow
like as he's like disintegrating like
wow um
uh ismail montoya i think super chat my
thoughts on episode five and six well
um
i think by the end i think episode six
the multiverse is going to
completely break into madness um oh yeah
for sure right i think that's what
happened i think it's just going to be
completely into madness
i think i think next episode
will it'll be revealed who is
in charge and then i think the final
episode is going to be
taking that person down um infinity
shade you say i missed a big super chat
is that the thor's hammer one because i
thought i addressed that uh i do think
loki is going to be
be worthy eventually i really really do
um
sorry guys let me try to address all
these super chats i don't i don't want
to miss any i also really have to use
the bathroom but i'm going to address
super chats first
uh i know the pirate man
uh okay no i missed it uh
jordan jordan
childers mobius never got his jet ski i
don't think he's dead
and if he is i'm just i i'm i'm
i'm gonna be so sad that he just goes
out like that he needs his jet ski
we got it like he's gotta have that
scene um
he's gotta have that scene uh an
infinity i i hope i addressed it if i
didn't
um put it in the comments i'll read it
but let me use the bathroom real fast
guys chris will entertain you
for the wait i will try to gather a
brain
oh daniel diaz you saw feige today at
the black widow premiere
so you're in london late for you or no
it's not late for you it's like middle
early for you right or early yeah
um yes hello everyone chris will
entertain you
as i as i run to the bathroom real fast
okay i'll try to gather my
thoughts holy cow everybody that was
absolutely
insane i mean on my chat over here most
people are just talking about trying to
contain their emotions
and for me it was mostly just i was
shocked and i think a lot of people are
saying it it's
this is the first thing the mcu's come
out with since infinity war
that has really left you just surprised
you know when thanos snapped infinity
war it was almost a surprise to all of
us a lot of us didn't see that coming
and it was absolutely incredible it was
absolutely insane
augie i see you over there on warren's
chat thank you for joining us me
but absolutely just game changing
episode
the next two episodes of loki are going
to alter
whatever is going to happen in the
future of the mcu
the post-credits scene was super cool it
shows us the pruning doesn't actually
delete characters all the way
and it changes the game forever and
that's the craziest bit
it's absolutely just a game-changing
episode and
there is rocket i see the rocket kitty
cat there's a rocket the game that's
rocket this is my cat rocket
so yeah i mean hi
say hi say hi
all right you can go oh
man what okay
all right so the villain has to be king
right i think so i think i think we can
unofficially confirm like i'm like
if it's not kang i will be very
surprised to see who it is
yeah really like i said we could
literally count on our fingers how many
people have the ability
that's the that's the thing is like who
who could make a sacred timeline all
this stuff
kang the master of time uh louis camacho
i think she is not a loki you're talking
about sylvie um i think she's low-key
we saw her like she's definitely
everything yeah
i definitely think she is um
yeah i definitely think she's loki um
but it would hey what a twist it would
be if
she wasn't huh um
man it's gotta be kang i mean
so loki's have this weird thing going on
here right mobius the best detective
in the tva has been studying and chasing
loki's
for years to the fact that they have a
whole group of them pruned
right so there is some weird key
to being a loki that the time keepers
or the kang right time keepers don't
exist
right have some issue with them right
right that that
that is a big thing to me that was
revealed
when they're in front of the timekeepers
where they're like oh they
they you brought us here just to kill us
it's like
i'm not going to say timekeepers because
i don't think there are time keepers
no i don't think there are i think it's
a person it's one person obviously it's
one entertainment call okay we'll see
okay we'll see let's call it thank you
let's let's call him
nathaniel because that's his real name
nathan origin so um
let let's go ahead and say nathaniel is
behind all of it
clearly so
okay let's let's think about it this way
if if kang
nathaniel timekeepers whoever the hell's
in charge wants a secret timeline
where they organize everything and it's
smooth
and it's clean what is your threat
mischief chaos
everything loki right is your
threat if you're trying to forge the
future
and create this timeline that is perfect
for you
that you know you want to rule and you
want to do all this stuff it's loki's
not not not low-key loki's
that screw it up because they're the
ones that
for starters they're chaos but they're
so smart
i mean they're and they're skilled and
they're crafty and they're cunning and
they're they're just a huge threat so
that's that's i mean that's 100
what it has to be just for the fun of it
hit me with you i'm still i'm still
leaning towards king
oh i think it's k but i in my heart
grow out there is there any possibility
it is
some variant of a loki
yeah right yeah i mean that's huge
that's a total possibility
a powerful character he is an underrated
character for his strength
it's possible it's a loki and that's the
reason loki's are the problem
right and like the greatest enemy is
myself
and the reason i feel that that could
actually somewhat be
more possible than kang is just because
of what's happened in falcon in the
winter soldier and
one division where at the end of the
episode you were expecting a big reveal
and what always happened it always
turned back to the title of the movie
one division
at the end right falcon in the winter so
maybe just following that trend
it's it's loki siri so loki's the bad
guy
yeah um
just trying to try to throw out i think
those are our two options i think
right it's kang or loki or it's loki
it's kangar loki a a version of loki um
and that would actually be odd i'd be
okay i'd be okay with either
i'd be all right seriously guess what
like that means i know i'm gonna take
myself
i know i'm gonna take myself down also
oh
man it might be loki what has been the
common theme
of loki so far superior location
okay and i'm i'm the superior loki
i am the right i'm the full of the lord
what if the main loki the main loki
not a variant but like the main loki is
in charge
he's lived out his life all the way down
the road and he created
he got away and he started it all over
no he didn't get away he's the main one
he's like the real one that everybody
else is a variant
of the one that gets killed by thanos
i don't know if that is the main one i
guess it is the main one because it
would have to be
according to the sacred timeline this is
where it gets messy
unless unless the real loki made
something happen he made the timeline
he created the second time there were
multiple timelines that could have
anything could have happened and he's
the one who got rid of them and compact
well here's the other thing
if it is loki uh hold on say it is loki
yeah all right go ahead go ahead before
these super chats go away i gotta
address them
john shin there's loki with the hammer
yes and i believe that we're gonna see
more of that
uh adi what did loki knew what was gonna
tell sylvia i think he was gonna tell
her they loved her
uh yeah trying to break the timeline
yeah
hold on they mentioned vampires for
blade i know for santos i i know that
was so cool
sam vista thanks so much for the super
chat i missed one i know i missed one
pie fire what if when you got pruned you
go to world war multiple versions of
yourself exist yeah i i think so right
like you go to your
world a world for you
uh vinnie maybe when you get pruned you
get put in the timeline with all the
print version of yourself based on yeah
that's that's what i that's what i'm
thinking too that's what i'm thinking
too
it's like you go to a world with just
you
right like you get sent to your own
your own thing jail yeah sam bestie
thinks that super chat if i didn't
mention it uh
and then there was a one more surren
sri ram sitharaman thanks for that super
chat
travis all again thanks for the super
chat room slayer has to have known that
timekeepers were fake she continued to
fight for somebody at the end
yeah i could be her um
although there was a judge when she was
like younger right so
i don't think she knew they were fake
personally you don't think she knew they
were fake i mean first thing she yelled
at was protect
protect the time keepers yeah but that's
that's like to keep
on the facade i don't know she came out
and she was all shaken up talking to
mobius it didn't seem like she was
faking
well he could have the real person could
have revealed himself there but yeah
maybe maybe but why does she still
kill loki i don't think right why
because well why would she kill loki
after
she no she has to know because she would
have been like what what is this my
whole life's a lie she knows
right and she lied to moebius about uh
c20 dying and everything like
like she knows she's in it yeah she's
clearly for the fiverr
it says great video chris i would ask a
question but i'm still mind blown
yeah i think that's true that was a
crazy episode
so i don't know i'm actually i when i
was saying this i was just kind of
saying this as a
as you know the devil's in the details
why not but i'm actually kind of
convinced it actually might be like
it's it's loki himself is going to be
the villain
and then kane gets all pissed off
because loki's messing around with time
and that's his thing and then
then he shows up at like the end the
post-credits scenes saying let me show
you how it's really done
there you go have a good night everybody
else
i mean so i called in the beginning that
the timekeepers were fake i just felt
like that was
a thing yeah the whole thing was a big
huge propaganda facade right
and and i think we narrowed it down
though i think it's kang or or
of a loki and from the sasha's king of
chicago
they're in their own variant heaven
slash hell yeah that would make sense
too wouldn't it
uh danny corona can't be another loki
ukrainian timeline that is in order
the opposite what he embodies he's
mischief yeah but you never know one
loki could
let's call it evolve what's called
involved
and chris made a good point like what if
you know the
the these shows one division falcon and
water soldier they oh they all
circle back to them
right right what is it really about them
and that could be it
uh kevin hdc mobius went to a universe
with himself
and jet skis how awesome would that be
just just a bunch of money he's like
leave me here i'm good i don't want to
go back come get me don't come get me
i'm just on a jet ski how cool would
that be
um humor super chat sam vesti again
thank you so much i reckon the whole
time keeper thing was a diversion
from the the time keepers
that they are real but trying to make
themselves fake ah maybe
my chat's rating the episode right now
rating it
rating oh 11 out of 10 10 out of 10 10
9 out of 10. 9.6 out of 10 10 out of 10
10 out of 10 10 out of 10 10 out of 10.
everybody do you think we'll see yeah i
think it's kang
or like a god loki like a real god loki
right
um there was post credits saying dakota
sinclair yes i know i saw it and it was
pretty awesome
um all the different variations of loki
um yeah so
luke luo ravona equals king's lover so
yeah that's another thing to to
keep in mind that's another thing to
keep in mind ravona in the comics is
kang's love yeah but she could also get
there the actress today was talking
about it because they were talking about
her potential future in the mcu
and she said this is her origin story so
maybe she's not there yet
yeah but clearly there's been a lot
that's happened
she she took in kid loki as a hunter so
clearly stuff's happened
and and and um
mobius did mention oh that's your other
analyst right your secret analyst so
yeah i agree i'm just saying i i don't
know i think maybe
i don't know if that's there just yet
but if i mean okay we'll put it this way
if kang is
the guy behind the tva then yeah it's
happening if it's not i don't think it's
happening just yet
true daniel d if i if i get you excited
about kang i could have apisto it's not
him i'll pull my hair
i'm not chris makes a good point with
loki
but here's the difference between
mephisto and kang kangas confirmed to
come he's going to be played by jonathan
majors he's coming in ant-man and the
lost quantum mania
so that's why i'm basing this off of
like facts already
right it's not it's not a witch hunt
we're not yeah i'm not like making
things
i'm not finding the devil in the details
right like it's it's like
literally we were like with one division
the stork when she tried to do magic on
it had red puff and we're like
right like this is that was reaching and
grasping at straws right
this is like something that we know is
coming uh kevin htc again
he should have ee with the gator loki he
didn't frock thor how funny would that
be
uh gary lopez think of super chat
wouldn't it be ironic that silvia is
actually
odin's biological daughter meaning she
is actually his guardian
that can be why she is blonde like thor
well you know what's interesting
is first of all yeah that would be
really cool then they actually
wouldn't be related not completely it
would be the same
person but not really no he's completely
adopted adopted
that would be a good way to keep it not
inside that could also be why
he seems to be more powerful than that
because
yeah pure straight up odinson yeah
daughter t nasty nelson we still have to
have the loki for president
that says what did you expect that loki
will be in prune world i think
by the way three portland oregon reps
and
references and that's cool that's cool
thanks super chat yeah we do still have
that lucky for president one
uh yeah dillard b
commons vampires mobius sounds like more
more ps
just noticed that since they were said
back to back yeah i mean i definitely
think that was a setup
for blade uh for sure so my channel is
in my chat
saying the loki with the hammer is known
as boastful
loki those two i've actually never heard
of
uh let's see if they're
i've never heard of it either um no i've
never heard of a boastful loki i've
heard of every other one of them
including gator loki but i've never
heard of boastful loki
that's interesting and
there's what an episode what a reveal
yeah that that what a job
is mobius in the same prune world as
loki so there's a few directions that
could go with this
and warren mentioned one where each loki
or each
character of the world goes to its own
garbage can
when they get pruned which is where all
the loki's are going together as they
get pruned
right so it's possible mobius goes to
his own little world which is all
a bunch of mobiuses well yeah i mean in
reality that's one like
mobius is right another theory is
and we've been talking about it on the
stream right now is
loki has some type of element to him
that
the person behind the tva can't
necessarily control
whether that's because the person behind
the tva is loki
or there's something else going on that
we don't know it's a god of mischief
destroying order kind of deal
and that's why he existed and it's
possible mobius is gone i don't think he
is but it's possible
yeah i don't really think so uh no i
don't either yeah but it's just
something a realistic possibility yeah
jabbazaro thanks for the super chat uh
why haven't we seen thor yet i know it's
loki's show
and thor has his own movie but it seems
author isn't it yeah i don't know maybe
they just
really wanted to keep the attention of
lucky you know maybe that's just
maybe that's what they're going for um
and also we have two episodes left so
you never know
mello b theory there's always been a
multiverse it's just this universal
timeline hasn't been exposed to it
i mean that's always a possibility right
um
the sacred timeline exists inside of
this universe that
they don't know exists right
it's it's hard to believe that someone
could compact a whole multiverse
just to a sacred timeline like one
timeline so i agree with you hey alexa
oh he's coming in with super chat super
appreciate it happy to be here again i'm
happy you're here
doing a great job thank you so much uh
do i think mobius was pruned to ancient
egypt
maybe that leaked scene of mobius at the
sphinx could be true
yeah um so in all honesty i've only
heard about this scene
and i've seen the leaked pictures but i
never saw
like the tv spot or wherever they
originally said it came from i haven't
actually seen it so
i don't know if that's real or not it
it kind of seems like something that
would be real it seems like they would
you know kind of go visit that
so i'm 50
50. but i don't think mobius is dead i
think that would be a shame
uh next thing for super chat wait miss
minutes is a leader now to think of it
because she has a clock
she can rewind like wanda's nexus power
they they did say that we haven't seen
the end of miss minutes
uh so i'm not surprised
if she has something to do with
something
uh kevin hdz again they mentioned
nightmare department maybe there yeah
that's true
that's that's very true they didn't
mention the nightmare department
that could that could be something
i mean that's to me that's kind of a
setup for doctor strange right with
you know right it's just a little name
dropping well nightmare was supposed to
be
the right the villain for that um
oh man so much crazy episode
crazy episode bite like to me this was
the best episode we've got from a marvel
series yet
i mean this is the best thing marvel's
done since it was this
and then right below this was agatha in
one division
and the only reason that was not as
exciting as because everybody knew
the real question was what was her
involvement everybody knew calling that
verb yeah
nobody saw mobius get improved nobody
yeah
not like that i that literally i just i
yelled so hard
luke hello again thanks for super chat
kang victor von doom
mephisto prime candidates doom has a
bigger chance if by comics did
similar a few times and do you miss less
even highway metal
after fantastic four's kids are born
i just don't know if they would throw
more episodes on solo
i don't know if they would throw doom in
right now um
and especially with like kang confirmed
to be coming you know
but i like where your head's at and it's
a 100 a possibility
um yeah i had a thought it could be doom
like one over the whole
battle world scenario well i mean that's
that's straight comics right he
in the world he takes the power of the
beyonce that's what i thought but i
thought maybe that's too
earlier too early for him probably is i
think especially for building secret
wars years into the future
so matt hutch thank you super chat hi
madison
good luck sleeping remember loki's like
loki's so if it were
loki the main timeline loki wouldn't
have died they wouldn't be hunting
loki's that was
a lot to say but i think i understand
what you're saying
look he's like okay so for look at the
main timeline
loki wouldn't have died uh maybe
um i still think that if
it like it could be like a king loki and
he knows that he's a threat to himself
like i think that's 100 percent
something that could be happening not
is happening but something that could be
happening i know i miss some super chats
and i don't want to miss the super chats
christopher quinones slayer can come
catch these hands yeah man
for real uh i hated her by the end of
that yeah
i mean for real her lying to mobius just
over and over so she obviously knew
something was up right yeah i mean
she i mean it seems like she
killed uh c15 c2
c20 yeah you see 20 just be fatino she
knows something
she knows something that we don't know i
mean she knows everything it seems like
elijah bell that's funny if loki is
behind
it it could be a version called i cool
look you backwards
i like that i am i cool i am king loki
uh dang
guys
i mean so i'm just i just i just think
like
the time travel thing the quantum realm
theory
it all to me really points to kang
but chris makes a really good point with
like going back to
to it being loki and like
i could totally see loki being the main
villain like
you know i i see that tim harper is like
the fourth one it's a hard one
yeah tim harper's and that's like the
fourth time loki has died on screen
maybe looking so we are trying to trick
her and slayer
this was all part of their main plan so
the only
thing i have against that is i their
magic doesn't
work inside the tv right for whatever
reason and i was actually thinking about
that today
i was like what is happening because the
quantum realm
shouldn't prevent them from doing their
power so i was like maybe they're not
the quantum realm
maybe they are maybe that's pretty man i
don't know i mean
whoever we're dealing with is somebody
truly powerful yeah
and and that's that's what i'm saying um
like the candidates are few
loki himself okay
uh jonathan sanchez this is how loki
becomes president loki
yeah i wonder if there's just
i wonder what i wonder what the the
trick
is right like at the end like there's a
there's a loki trick coming
there's gotta be right yeah han solo q
a loki kang hybrid lokang
t nasty nelson citadel at the end of
time is in
egypt time keep its quarters
yeah and oh man you know what
i have a theory but it's like it's
it's way too far out there like
because kang at one point in time
um
is like i don't want to say raising
training
like apocalypse to take over
like his role in egypt and stuff and
that's when his plan is thwarted by
the fantastic four so it's like
ancient egypt apocalypse
something i have to do with aaron kang
you know like
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
think about that thomas briscoe jr i
wonder if lizard loki is
from the same universe of spider-ham hey
you never know
um
finds death full of infinity stones
yeah the city in the quantum realm with
the bubble around it the bubble could be
some type of preventing
oh that's true yeah thanks forever said
that uh
big head big
second command here there you go kang
equals loki variant
you know that would be a cool twist
in all honesty it would be a cool twist
if he was just a variant of loki and
he's the one who
figured it out um and that
hey and that would make both of our
theories combined into one right chris
like yeah there you go it is loki but it
is kang
that cosmic culture theory
i guess that's me that's why moby is in
egypt
the citadel wonder theory i mean yeah
that's a
that's a good point to nasty nelson um
i my mind is going crazy right now i'm
i'm like my i'm spitting through like
i'm just sitting here just staring at
nothing
so much and honestly what a cool turnout
from all you guys
the fans of marvel who obviously loved
what we just saw
yeah i mean i mean really um
william f according to some lego leagues
the figure for sofia d
martino's lucky variant is said to come
with a hairpiece
with a diadem a green jade blade and a
baby crocodile well we've seen her with
the diadem and with the the green blood
i mean there might be another
version of lady loki somewhere oh there
there should be right i mean
right there's more than just the one i
mean if there's all these guy loki's
there's gonna be a bunch of girl lookies
um corn thank you knows more
entertainment how you doing welcome to
the stream
same thing happened in one division to
be honest i got the cast of the spell
that suppressed wanda from using her
magic in her basement could be similar
situation
yeah and that bubble could very well be
something right to keep out the weird
animals that we saw on ant-man and
the wasp at the end but also to maybe
suppress all magical abilities
uh t magic infinity thanks for super
chat sylvia's probably not odin's
biological daughter because of her
blonde hair
and the flashback when she was taken by
the tv her hair was black right yeah i
i noticed that i was actually said to
one point in time
in the chat i was like why is her hair
blonde now did she just dye her hair to
try to escape the tv magic she could
probably change it to whatever she's
magic she probably
could just boom but if one of the loki's
is from the sam raimi universe and they
reveal it in the sixth episode in a
post-credits scene
like here's a picture of the spider-man
from my universe and it's toby mcguire
right yeah how funny would that be
that's how they do it all and
here's the trailer of the new movie
right that would be so freaking funny
i wouldn't even know what to do next
yeah i know i would just like kind of
sit there pretty much be like i'm going
to bed guys we'll see you tomorrow
i need like time to wrap my head around
this process
and like right now i don't even know
like
good night sakai thank you i don't know
what to think right now uh jordan kohler
who are the dudes in the post
post-credit scenes with loki they were
loki
they were different versions of loki kid
loki
comic accurate loki um
and what did they call what does some
people call the other one somebody what
uh something with a bee boastful
okay boastful which i haven't still
don't know if i've ever heard of it
before
yeah so we'll have to check that out
does anybody know who
uh the african-american location hammer
hammer wielding loki
um i know they're all located right i
mean they're all loki
so yeah and they could make some up they
don't all have to be comic book based as
well
yeah i don't think
i don't think the timekeepers are real
just like i've thought the whole another
time i i thought they were fake the
older oh
sylvie did say she was adopted no she
did
yeah she said it and she knew the whole
time that she was adopted yeah she said
she was dumb she was like yeah
look at they told you i mean they told
me eventually yeah yeah i mean they told
me eventually
yeah man
oh my brain dude we're supposed to work
after this
i know that's why i'm like i'm kind of
like sitting there
like trying to freaking wrap my head
around it yeah
um matthew king what's up do i think the
show connects snow at home
yeah i think this sets the premise for
the the
multiverse to go in the madness and that
that goes on their way home
and then it goes into doctor strange uh
marvin estrada i think super chat do i
think mobius could be king
uh i actually mentioned that at one
point in time like a variant of him
could be kang
but but no i don't i don't think so
uh ismael montoya thanks for another
super chat loki's love for silvia would
break the timeline
that's what they said right that's the
nexus event
right it was literally exactly what they
were talking about like
it happened right when he or she touched
she like grabbed his arm and he was like
falling in love with her slash himself
that was a nexus event that was created
the title of the of the episode is
nexus event right yup the index is a bit
so so the question
is in regards to the post credit scene
is it a is it loki's
that have come together and they have
trapped and they've tracked
our loki down and they've like been
waiting for him
or is it like a loki world where all the
loki's get sent to
because they were waiting for him and he
said am i dead and he's like
and they were like yeah
right you gotta come with us right right
so something's coming
i think well you gotta imagine these
aren't the
only two loki's trying to take down the
tva right i mean if there's
thousands and thousands of loki's
variants
well that's what i was saying about
mobius has been studying loki's
for forever right so loki has a special
element
that goes against whatever the creator
of the tva's agenda is
and that's why there's so many of them
that have just been deleted
right or like that's that's almost
guaranteed to be somewhat accurate
somehow maybe we'll get that explanation
in the next episode like why are there
so many loki variants like
oh well the dude in charge hates us
because right we're mischief and he's
order whatever the heck the explanation
is
our magic can't be contained we're
actually more powerful than we even
thought you know
so here's something that's interesting
though
sylvie said that the universe wants
chaos
and that goes against the tva
so i wonder if like the universe just
like
in the comics is like beans like
eternity
right yeah and it fits yeah right so
i wonder if this truly is about to bring
in
the cosmic side living tribunal you know
we're getting the celestials um
as eternity gonna come in stuff like
that like
that's what i'm really curious about uh
javier elias
love your content everybody ready for
tom cruise sony stark thank you so much
yeah i mean it's like
it's looking that we're gonna get these
different variants right uh
that have kind of been you know rumored
and speculated for about now i think
it'd be really cool
i think it'd really really really be
cool
so oh man
it was cool that they did it in this
third episode because nobody was
expecting it oh
if they waited to do something like this
until episode six we would be expecting
it yeah the fact that it happened
episode three we weren't really nobody
thought mobius was gonna get that
nobody thought loki was gonna get that
the timekeepers reveal all that
happening in episode three
was such good writing yeah i mean really
because it really did
make it so much more exciting
i lo i i truly love the experience of
this one i haven't been this
oh it's super emotional on a tv show
in a long time when i say emotional i
mean like mad
like i i i was shook
i was legitimately
pissed off and then i got even more
pissed off and then i was like okay i
think we're all right
because all i want i want two things
i want mobius on a freaking jet ski by
the end of this freaking show
and i kind of want loki and somebody to
get together as weird as it sounds i'm
saying yeah i
i wanted that screw it i'm saying it i
wanted to happen if that's what it takes
for loki
to have peace and and love and
tranquility
for him to love himself i'm for it was
funny because moby is whacked out right
on the head he's like you're
such a narcissist he could only fall in
love with yourself
that was great oh that whole scene where
mobius just
blocked him and every turn was pretty
impressive that was pretty great
and he just called him on his lies and
stuff like that
um
oh man oh somebody said something i just
lost it
i can't find it that that one
person could be a variant of thor with
the hammer
it's possible that's possible i think
i'm thinking they're sticking to loki
though gotta be a loki right that's what
we're going for here
i definitely think he doesn't have any
horns or any head piece but he's got the
chest piece
i mean there is a time in the comics
that thor
or loki has mulener as well could be
worthy thor
or worthy loki yeah i mean there's
there's a lot of possibilities
uh let me see if i can
find the music was super cool yeah let
me see if i can find you said it
uh i'm looking through the chat
someone said council of the kings and i
want to give proper credit
because i like that idea
um dang well whoever said it
do it right there jeremy stickell
if you were the first person to say
kudos to you
i really think i mean i
i've been convinced since the beginning
that it is kang
because it just makes sense like it just
makes sense now it also makes sense if
loki is behind at all
that is kind of a problem it makes too
much sense but when you have the
confirmation that king is coming within
two years
right um no i agree
up until i put this whole idea of loki
together i actually was
very convinced it was king
it could be like
like a mortise which is a
very king right it's okay
it's really weird other than loki i
can't really think of anybody that they
would put
yeah it makes any sense it's really
weird how they're like the different
versions of kang have like different
names yeah different person
completely different stories yeah right
like a whole different thing
scarlett centurion um
really nathaniel richards that's what he
does he's the master of time travel he's
the master of
all of this i mean it just it makes
sense to me
it just makes so much sense to me
oh man
well we've got a lot to rapper oh did i
miss some super chats
uh be leaf 789 in the post credit scene
why
did the old loki's outfit look like
halloween costume i think we're getting
king too uh i think it's just
that version is like the comic accurate
version i think that's just like a node
to like
us like s fans uh jabber twenty seven
nobody else's jets
ski saying wow that'd be a perfect post
credit scene psle content thank you so
much yeah that's
like literally like i like i just said
like i want two things i want mobius on
a jet ski
i don't think he's gonna say wow because
they said he's not going to but they
could just say that to throw us off and
i want sylvian loki to get together
like that's that's what i want
that is what i want well guys we have a
lot to
do now we have a lot of work we got some
videos to bust
and i have to wrap my head around this
yeah just like think what i
like stoked i i think i'm
stuck bro um
uh for a few people who are asking who
kang is he's basically the master of
time
travel uh there's a bunch of different
variants
of him yeah yeah i've done videos on
loki before
um there's definitely so basically he's
master time he doesn't have any like
special abilities or anything like that
he
he simply is the master of time travel
and he's
originally from the future and he just
kind of takes over a bunch of different
places and becomes just incredibly
powerful
so um
yeah and it could be the council of the
kings it could it could be you know more
than one of them and now i'm kind of
thinking like
a mortis but let's see about that
so um
yeah so a lot to talk about a lot to you
know
dissect man um haiti
predictions for episode five love
joining live streams thank you so much
and thank you so much for that super
chat
uh i'm thinking uh i think episode five
is gonna be a reveal of
who's really behind it i think the other
loki's might know in the post-credits
scene we see the other loki's
i think they might know and we might not
find out to the end
of episode five but they're like they're
gonna reveal it in episode five
or i'm gonna use that or they're going
to
reveal in the beginning of episode six
which i feel like they shouldn't do i
feel like we need more time in episode
six so
i feel like in episode five they should
reveal
the bad the big bad um
yeah uh they definitely need to if for
some reason loki ends and we don't know
who it is
that'll be a kick in the balls yeah
well um
yeah what an episode what an episode me
too bro
yeah um guys we're gonna go ahead and
say stop the super chats now because
we're about to get off and i don't want
to miss any super chats since the stream
is like
delayed by i don't know 30 seconds or
something like that
uh richard e grant is playing
old the old loki so
uh so time travel power is for them
saying that can't explain nullified
infinity stones i mean
if you travel far enough into the future
and obtain like because remember in thor
where they said like you call it science
we call it magic they're one and the
same
it's almost like like if you go further
from the future
like the advancements in things you're
gonna like
electric mugnet like emps electric
magnetic pulse
that you know like turn off electricity
in our real life right now they didn't
have that 100 years ago you know what i
mean so there is like technology that
kang could come upon to
prevent stuff like that right so you
know essentially if you travel further
enough in the future
and that's kind of what he does he like
gets weapons and stuff so
that that's that's really what it is so
all right guys we
we're hopping off and we got some work
to do and go
geez what an episode a crazy episode
i loved it it was the best so far out of
any of the episodes from marvel that we
got at disney plus
that was amazing i'm gonna find my
reaction to when moby is
concept and i'm just gonna post it and
oh my gosh that is
uh yeah okay so
um wow thank you everybody for stopping
by today
everybody who commented everybody who
super chatted everybody who just sat in
the background
and watched and just you know decided on
the conversation appreciate all of you
love all you uh you make this so much
fun
and uh yeah uh one last super chat game
over do you think loki will have a
crucial role in the next mcu phase i
hope so and i hope
sylvia is right there with him i i
really do
so all right guys
we're going to get to work do some
videos hope you guys enjoyed them we're
going to put them out in a few hours so
be on the lookout love you all don't
forget to
subscribe to chris at cosmic culture
chris drop a link
real fast uh shout out go go go go go go
go
for being a great mod as always an
incredible job there's cosmic culture
right there don't forget to subscribe to
chris i'm on that channel too we are
roommates today
i was on that channel today talking
about fast and the fear
but anyways anyways um
yeah thank you everybody for stopping by
we're gonna get to work love you all